What do I think of bedbed? So bedbed is all is a dewormer and bedbed is all
is the name of the you were were given to animals. We have a number of people
on bedbed is all are there downsides of bedbed is all using bedbed is all well
it is a drug are there downsides to it maybe have I ever seen any downsides to it
no I've had a couple people said gave in the stomachache but I don't know if
it was that bedbed is all they gave in the stomachache I think that was more
in their head they thought they were scared because they don't ever take drugs
and they took it they thought they had a stomachache you can take it with food you
shouldn't get a stomachache with it you're really taking as much as you would
give a 10 pound dog so if you weigh 130 180 pounds you're taking such a low
dose of it you really should not have any side effects of it is it going to
deworm your body is it going to affect your microbiota there's no there's no
studies that I've seen that it damages your microbiota and at that dose if
you're probably not going to do a whole lot of deworming of you anyhow the whole
it's a totally different mechanism that's happening with bedbed is all in
cancer and we have seen it help a lot of people we have a lot of people taking
bed is on a number of you on this call maybe on bed is on it is it can be a
great thing to and to your protocol